the Hulk has been a popular fixture in
the MCU for years but it wasn't until
later films like thor ragnarok infinity
war and endgame that the Hulk narrative
was really let off the leash here's a
rundown of the Hulk's hidden MCU trilogy
Hulk kicked things off in the MCU back
in 2008 with the Incredible Hulk the
story wasn't exactly a bad one but it
wasn't a great one either especially
considering the caliber of so many of
the Marvel movies that came after it
part of the issue with Hulk's
non-starter in the MCU was the fact that
the movie picked up partway into the
story and proceeded to go kind of
nowhere the movie introduces Banner
after he's already become the Hulk
skipping right over his infamous gamma
radiation incident in the process of
course that doesn't automatically equate
to a negative
Captain Marvel also jumps right into the
story as it's already developing the
difference however is that carol danvers
film circles back around to show how she
got her superpowers The Incredible Hulk
simply charges ahead assuming everybody
already knows about the whole gamma
radiation thing things still could have
turned out alright if the film had ended
in an appropriate place but once again
it manages to drop the ball while the
climactic fight against abomination is
fun the movie ends with banner finally
coming to terms with Hulk which would
have been great if Marvel didn't then
retcon it in The Avengers
sadly a meandering storyline is just the
beginning of the incredible hulks
problems another issue with the film is
its excessively serious nature which
contrasts starkly against Iron Man's
light and witty tone Edward Norton's
version of Bruce Banner is silky serious
and spends most of the film depressed
while the character is certainly an
improvement over the version seen in
angley's Hulk which came out half a
decade earlier it just doesn't fit the
MCU stone the movie just feels like it
belongs in an entirely different
universe than that of Tony Stark another
complication that surfaced was the
growing tension between Norton and
Marvel Studios that's not to say that
Norton wasn't committed to the role on
the contrary the Academy award-nominated
actor brought a lot of vision and depth
to the character but when the rubber hit
the road things just didn't fit well
behind the scenes in the ensuing fallout
the actor and the studio parted ways not
on the most pleasant of terms and the
Hulk found himself at a crossroads
while characters like Spider Man the ex
man and the Fantastic Four have all had
clear-cut rights issues over the years
many of which have been ironed out over
time one stubborn conundrum that has
refused to resolve itself as the
question of the Hulk's rights putting it
as simply as possible the rights to Hulk
are kind of split between Marvel and
Universal Marvel Studios is allowed to
use the Hulk character in its movies a
right they regained back in 2005 after
Universal failed to pull the trigger on
a sequel to angley's Hulk
however Universal still retains the
right of first refusal for any solo Hulk
film which allows them to distribute any
Hulk movie that's made that complicating
little concern along with the fact that
the Incredible Hulk performed relatively
poorly at the box office
pushed Marvel to abandon any efforts to
make another Hulk movie when everything
was taken into consideration the
Incredible Hulk - just wouldn't have
been worth the time and effort it would
have required while his first MCU for a
seemed to Peter out after just one film
hope would eventually get a second
chance distribution rights may have made
for tough sledding with a Hulk solo
movie but over the following years
Marvel rehabilitated the jave giant by
utilizing him as an effective and
interesting supporting character this
began with casting Mark Ruffalo in the
role a wise move considering the actor
instantly won over the hearts of the
fans when he arrived on screen banners
MCU storyline was also largely reset he
was back to not getting along with the
Hulk and was clearly scared of letting
the other guy get in the driver's seat
the banner Hulk combo made a big splash
with audiences in the Avengers leading
to the decision to have Banner pop in
for a quick counseling session with Tony
Stark in the post-credits scene for Iron
Man 3 Banner and Hulk showed up again in
the second Avengers film in which they
both play a major role in bringing down
Ultron's apocalyptic threat at that
point in the franchise however Hulk and
Banner were still just supporting
players in an ever-growing universe it
wasn't until 2017 that Ruffalo and
Marvel boss Kevin Feige had sat down to
chat about Hulk's future in the MCU it
was during this conversation that
Ruffalo and Feige decided to give the
Hulk his own so-called special trilogy
Feige and Ruffalo's conversation ended a
pinning hulk down to a single storyline
that would be split up over the course
of three other characters movies this
and sidestepped any distribution issues
by not casting Hulk is a main character
in any of the three films but it's still
allowed for plenty of time to create a
character arc with a meaningful impact
something Hulk hadn't experienced up to
that point things kick off at the very
end of age of Ultron with Hulk flying
off in the Avengers Quinn jet from there
he remains safely tucked away in space
as the events of a few more Marvel films
pass by including Captain America Civil
War in which his old nemesis general
fattiest Ross makes a point of
questioning Holt's whereabouts
The Avengers reforms to make the world a
safer place I feel we've done tell me
captain do you know where a Thor and
Banner are right now the Infinity Saga
doesn't find Hulk in the flesh again
until thor ragnarok in which the lord of
thunder discovers his friend from work
on the garbage planet of Sekar hoax
presents throughout Ragnarok is the
perfect complement to Thor's story but
at the same time it also serves as a
vehicle to propel his own story through
the first third of its three movie arc
after their electrifying first encounter
in the Grand Master's arena the two
friends have a long and lightning and
downright hilarious conversation that
demonstrates a new side to Hulk's
character while he's still very rough
around the edges the big guy has clearly
matured during his time on Sekar over
the course of their conversation Hulk
speaks in fuller sentences and reveals
his attachment to his new banner free
life nevertheless shortly afterward the
pair visit the Quinjet we're recording
of Natasha Romanoff helps banner regain
control for the first time in years from
there the good doctor joins the
newly-minted team of revenge errs and
heads off to Asgard to help Thor unseat
hella it's on Asgard that the first
portion of the characters trilogy
concludes in a movie filled with Hulk
smashing arguably the most heroic moment
comes when Banner willingly allows Hulk
to regain control knowing he may never
come back in order to save Asgard the
film ends with the character still
hooked out and living on the refugee
ship with the surviving Asgardians
headed for Earth
things went quickly south for the Hulk
during infinity war which was released
the following year the third Avengers
film opens with the s guardianship
already overrun by Thanos and Hulk ends
up right in the
only a few minutes into the film but
this time things don't go according to
plan and the Green Machine ends up down
for the count after taking a few blows
from a savvy opponent at that point I'm
doll uses the last of his strength to
summon the Bifrost and send Hulk
hurdling back to earth where he arrives
in NYC
back in banner form from then on Hulk
flat out refuses to join the fight fans
believed that Hulk would play some part
in the fight against Thanos but the
deliberate withdrawal of the character
after infinity wars opening scene
ultimately makes his arc that much more
interesting the truth is Hulk had been
little more than a pawn and the Avengers
plans up until this point often only
whipped out to save the day when danger
was about to strike his time on Sekar
gave him a taste of freedom and the big
guy liked it co director Joe Russo
explains it best people speculated
whether there was some fear on the
Hulk's part about having a face stay
honest again but I think ultimately what
it is is that he's tired of playing hero
in the lead-up to infinity war Mark
Ruffalo revealed in an interview that
Bruce Banner and the Hulk were headed
for a showdown while the hint seemed to
point toward a violent conclusion the
rest of Hulk's three-part story actually
ended up playing out in an unexpected
way for a character who was so often
used as an explosive plot device or as a
way to entertain smash happy fans the
pivotal moment for Hulk and banner ended
up being relatively quiet not only that
but it actually took place off screen
when audiences caught up with Hulk again
in endgame the instead ran into
Professor Hulk the long-awaited union of
the two personalities was the result of
18 months of lab-based gamma exposure
leading to the perfect combination of
Banner and Hulk I put the brains and the
Brawn together and now they give me best
of both worlds while the transformative
scene itself was originally meant for
infinity war it ended up being the
perfect way to launch the third and
final part of the Hulk's arc as endgame
plays out so twos does the third and
final portion of Hulk's three-part story
arc looking back it's hard to believe
that this is the same character who just
a handful of years earlier had
maintained a successful gladiatorial
career half a galaxy away by endgame
Hulk is refined thoughtful and caring he
even watches his past self smashing his
way through New York City and declares
it
the banner part of his intellect allows
the whole character to finally interact
as a normal adult human being he's
instrumental in convincing Thor to stop
sulking and pick up Stormbreaker for
another go at Thanos he's also able to
process the loss of Black Widow without
causing much physical damage most
important of all however it's Hulk who
tracks down the ancient one and
convinces her to surrender the time
stone consequently Hulk is also the only
one shown the negative effects that
stealing the Infinity stones would have
on time this place is the responsibility
squarely in his hands to make sure
everything gets put back in place after
the Avengers victory while the third
portion of Holt's three movie arc is
packed with some great stuff there's one
thing that stands out from all the rest
reversing fan else's snap ultimately it
ends up being Hulk and Hulk alone who
wields Starks Infinity Gauntlet and
brings everyone back from the dead it's
an utterly selfless move and one that
Hulk wouldn't have volunteered for at
any other time in his life the added
fact that the radiation emanating from
the gauntlet is mostly gamma lends a
pleasing touch of Destiny to the act as
he takes the gauntlet and snaps his
fingers to put it in his own words it's
like he was made for this it's a
triumphant and breathtakingly worthy way
to end a story that began all the way
back at the end of Avengers age of
Ultron check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]